getting worse the 95 is not the place to  be at right now we have this crash  blocking the left lane we already have  reduced lanes for the ongoing road  project  this crash is on the 95 southbound at  eastern you see the traffic there  squeezing by through just one lane  and this is the backup the same drivers  are running into a separate incident as  we pull up the camera here  this other incident is right here looks  like two vehicles just stopped and  that's also creating even more backup  for those  this is closer to las vegas boulevard  against southbound 95  and it's even creating even more backups  it's getting even more red right now  also that backup is stretching over to  what looks like rancho now possibly it's  mlk and now inching closer to rancho so  again the 95 not the place to be either  find another alternate route or  just plan some additional travel time  we'll be back